for Israeli soldiers three women and a
man were killed in Jerusalem on Sunday
more than a dozen were injured three
reportedly in serious condition the
attacker a Palestinian married man in
his twenties with Israeli citizenship
plowed a truck into them another example
of using a truck as a weapon we are
going to show you some of the
surveillance footage of this incident
while I describe what happened this is
an individual who previously served time
in prison and camera footage that was
shot from a distance shows the truck
racing towards a group of soldiers
standing by their bus driving through
the group scattering bodies and after a
delay of a few seconds you see the truck
starting to reverse into them again and
that is when witnesses said by and large
they realized this was not a car
accident but this was a deliberate act
of terror the driver was ultimately shot
dead by other soldiers and a tour guide
with the group that was hit eyewitnesses
who arrived said that they saw all sorts
of horrible things including a body
under the trucks wheels other bodies
beside the truck and of course the
driver dead behind the windshield this
is the deadliest Palestinian attack in
Jerusalem and month uh no connection to
Isis currently Palestinians without
links to Isis have used this method
before in terms of the reaction Hamas is
qassam brigades said that the Jerusalem
ramming a talk attacker was indeed a
released prisoner and a statement from
the group refers to him as a Mujahid a
jihadi fighter Hamas also put out a
statement saying that the operations of
Israel in the West Bank and Jerusalem
prove that the Jerusalem Intifada is not
an isolated event but rather a decision
by the Palestinian people to revolt
until they attain freedom and liberation
the sister of the terrorists driving the
truck called it quote most beautiful
martyrdom now that there is a political
context here and I want to be super
clear okay I can't say that this
incident was specifically related to
this but like I've said before
after Donald Trump selected Pro
settlement David Friedman as an
ambassador to Israel the US Secretary of
State John Kerry said this this could
have consequences if Trump follows
through with unilaterally moving the US
Embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem I'm
not blaming Trump for this at all I want
to be super clear if I see comments
saying I'm blaming Trump I'm gonna
ignore them because I'm telling you
right now that that's not what I'm doing
I think that we have to unequivocally
condemn and do everything that we can do
to prevent these acts of terror all I am
saying is that there are political
decisions that can be made which will
make this type of incident worse more
likely to happen uh and there are
decisions that can be made that might
might get us closer to realistic peace
talks to the israeli-palestinian
conflict the truth is that regardless of
what Trump did Palestinian leadership
has been encouraging young Palestinian
men to attack Israeli soldiers and
Israeli civilians and there are two
terrorism trends both predicted both
increasingly common free security or
outside of security airport attacks
which we've seen even over the weekend
and using trucks to drive through crowds
of people we saw it in Nice France we
saw it in Germany truck ramming is very
convenient think about it to do a
suicide vest attack which we used to see
a lot of in Jerusalem you need to get
explosives equipment learn how to build
it typically you can't do it by yourself
more than one person is involved you
steal a truck and you drive it into a
crowd Pat you'll likely kill as many
people as you would at least compared to
what some of the suicide vest attacks
have done and it is very difficult to
harden an entire city against these
runaway truck attacks yeah it's a very
concerning new style of terrorist attack
because when you think of something like
hijacking a plane there are many
measures of security that you you have
to go through before you enter a plane
or when we talk about a shooting there
are things like background checks and
not allowing people on a terrorist watch
list to obtain a weapon for something
like this when just about anyone can
drive or even if you take away their
license can steal a car it's much more
concerning some says if started bringing
out concrete jersey barriers to protect
prepossessed rien areas but the reality
is that it is
very very difficult and critical
buildings anticipate this if you look at
diplomatic buildings they have
perimeters they have very high security
standards they have barriers that are
fixed deep into the ground elevated
walls the buildings are set back you
just can't do that everywhere and this
is a real concern also al Qaeda in the
Arabian Peninsula talking about Yemen
published a debriefing report after the
nice uh truck attack and they said that
this is a method that they endorse and
are encouraging people to use so very
concerning news from over the weekend
we'll continue talking about it and the
implications remember that i'm on
twitter at d pakman follow me there
today's episode is made possible in part
by ziprecruiter if you are hiring you
need to know where to post your job to
find the best candidates and posting in
one place is just not enough you want to
find the perfect hire you should be
using all of the top job sites and now
you can with ziprecruiter which already
has nine million resumes you can search
through in their database you can add
people to your account to make it the
most efficient hire finding team
ziprecruiter dot-com lets you post your
job to 100-plus job sites including
social media networks like facebook and
twitter with a single click it's also a
search engine for finding and posting
jobs you can look for candidates in a
particular city or industry nationwide
you post once and you see the qualified
candidates start to roll in the zip
recruiters easy-to-use interface you
don't have to juggle emails or calls you
can screen rate and rank candidates
within the ziprecruiter system and if
you have any issues ziprecruiter has a
friendly and human support team ready to
help find out today why ziprecruiter has
been used by over 1 million businesses
you can go to ziprecruiter dot-com /
free trial that is ziprecruiter dot-com
/ free trial one more time try it for
free ziprecruiter com / free trial